a lot of what we see on the big screen
is created with computers and green
screens but some scenes are still filmed
in real places and occasionally once the
movie is done filming those sets are
just left behind to be reclaimed by
Nature
here are some eerie abandoned movie sets
you didn't know still exists big fish
Daniel Wallace's novel big fish is set
in the fictional Alabama town of Spectre
when Tim Burton adapted the movie for
the screen in 2003 crews built a real
Spectre complete with a church
storefronts and houses and it's still
there - a few buildings that are
collapsing or burned down fans of big
fish can still visit Spectre which is
housed on a private island outside of
Montgomery Alabama by paying a $3 toll
that's one big fish for a pretty small
fee were bummed the fugitive a standout
seen from this 1993 Oscar nominated
Harrison Ford thriller takes place when
a prison bus collides with a train
Richard Kimble escapes the wreckage to
become well you know oh good you do
anyway that crash wasn't CGI the crew
really did slam a train on a disused
portion of the Great Smoky Mountain
Railroad in North Carolina it cost 1.5
million dollars to stage and they only
had one tape to get it right rather than
clean it up the fugitive crew just left
a train and bus debris behind where it's
rusted over time it's quite visible on
many train excursions in the area not
only that is probably the only place you
should have this conversation I didn't
kill my wife I don't care
Star Wars some of the most recognizable
set pieces from the first Star Wars
movie still stand 40 years after filming
started standing in for Luke Skywalker's
desert home planet of Tatooine were the
deserts of Tunisia and on that terrain
set many instantly recognizable Star
Wars buildings including Luke
Skywalker's house parts of Mos Espa and
a bunch of other buildings are blend in
nicely with the desert just watch out
for all the Sun and unlike
gun girl one of the creepiest scenes in
gun girl shows police visiting an
abandoned Missouri more that has been
taken over by criminals and transients
the real more used in gone girl though
is actually the former Hawthorne Plaza
Mall in the Los Angeles suburb of
Hawthorne since shutting down in the 90s
the mall has been used quite a few times
in big-budget Hollywood movies including
Minority Report and evolution and yes as
hyper announcer in England remember
evolution if you don't please enjoy this
representative sample The Hunger Games
about a century ago Henry River Mill
Village in North Carolina was a textile
hub but when those jobs started to fade
away it turned into a ghost town that
made it an ideal shooting location for
the economically depressed district 12
in The Hunger Games Movies being
featured in one of the most popular film
series of all time has injected new
interest and cash into Henry River Mill
Village now Hunger Games fans can go
there and take a tour of Katniss
Everdeen home town just make sure you
get there before it's too late
there it's not district 12 talking on
iron man in the crucial opening scenes
of the first Marvel Cinematic Universe
entry Tony Stark has captured in
Afghanistan and imprisoned in a desert
cave by a terrorist cell the real-life
cave where this sequence was shot isn't
actually in Afghanistan though instead
the crews made their way to an abandoned
mineshaft in Cerro Gordo mines in
California pretty cool they wouldn't
take much to visit the set where Marvel
movie history was born I am Iron Man
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which movie set
you'd like to visit
[Music]